pull up a chair because the voice is
officially back for their seventh season
hey everyone I'm Liana Galera for ET now
voice veterans and founding members of
TV's best bromance Adam Levine and Blake
Shelton are back and this time they've
brought two new faces to the Emmy
award-winning series no doubts leading
lady Gwen Stefani and the man who
creates all the songs that get stuck in
your head producer Pharrell Williams to
kick off the new season and celebrate
the first night of blind auditions the
coaches took the stage to give fans with
a cover of one and Pharrell's 2001 hit
tell a good
well now that we've heard how it's done
let's get to know some of the best
singers from the first night of the
voices blind audition soul singer Luke
Wade was the very first contestant to
take the season 7 stage and he scored an
impressive 4 chair turn with his
rendition of Otis Redding's that's how
strong my love is
despite an accident with a paintball gun
that left him blind in the right eye
Luke never gave up on his dreams and he
has spent the past ten years trying to
catch his big break in the end he
decided that Pharrell was the best coach
to help him finally make it TSA agent
Damian delivered one of the best and
most emotional performances of the night
with his rendition of it's so hard to
say goodbye to yesterday
following his performance adamian broke
down in tears from happiness and despite
sharing a super-sweet moment with one
damien decided that Adam was the coach
for him there's no one else like Damien
in this competition
I can't wait to get into it with onward
make some magic 16 year-old Brianna
solace fell in love with music at an
early age
and she chose to sing ariana grande's
summer hit problem to show off her
powerful voice
Adam won and Blake were stunned when
they turned their chairs and each fought
hard to win the singer over however it
was one who played the girl card who
connected with Brianna the best
idea to make some team insurance ready
to go closing out the show was country
lover James David Carter who has been
the opening act for many big names in
Nashville even our own coach Blake
Shelton but this was James's time to
shine and his version of nobody knows
was so impressive that he made all four
chairs turn
despite some strong attempts from the
coaches to sway his vote
Wow
James happily chose to be a part of team
plates now I want to know what was your
favorite blind audition of the Boise
season 7 premiere senior on twitter
using the hashtag ET now and for more of
TV's top shows keep it locked to ET
online